and you feel the love tonight any
perfect harmony with
[Music]
now my lover I am irrationally happy
that you are simp I am so I don't know
why I just brings me so much freakin joy
it really does and I didn't even realize
that this is a lot of first for you your
first like voiceover animated your first
time with Disney how are you still
having purse it's no no I'm still having
first everything you know like it's a
big deal for me like I think this is a
it's a special moment for me like I got
to learn I mean for me I've been in the
business a while but to be able to work
with like you know Beyonce James Earl
Jones John Favreau
hi Connick people in this business is
like you know it's an amazing feeling I
know when I saw that cast photo I it
kind of hit me like whoa the magnitude
of this cast it was like wow a lot of
people it's a lot of good people like I
think John did a really good job I still
can't believe he kind of asked me I
really know I it was such a we were like
we were doing something else and he's
like can I talk to you on the side and I
thought he was gonna like be like Oh can
I sign something for like his son who I
heard was a fan and names like do you
want to be Simba and I was like me like
you really want me to do that I'm just
glad he asked yes right there on the
spot like you didn't have to see
anything I mean really can you really
say I'll think about it I know that I'm
saying like I don't want this you know
I'm in the day-night he's just gonna be
okay and then you know I mean like y'all
do it I already gave it to Michael B
Jordan I'm sorry you know like I can't
do it I didn't want to I don't want to
give it up said yes immediately I know
you're already super hero to your babies
but to get to like share this with them
is something iconic you know and they
see that in a whole new light you're
like the king hey you know it's funny
like my son this is my son's favorite
movie he's like a big animal person
I wasn't going to tell him I was in it
I'm just gonna let him see it and see
what happened and I was like hey do you
want to see The Lion King tomorrow
yesterday and he said yeah Beyonce's in
it right
I was like yeah daddy's in a to know
like daddy's in it you know so like
y'all saying it right exactly that's
what I'm saying I'm like her demo is
wide-reaching
like he's like she's super excited
though most took your please
and the circle of life
[Music]